[Music]
i was in the hospital due to her attempt
to suspend but that happened and you
know my mom
she already struggled with depression
and she just
it made it so much worse and hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
you didn't make it so much worse
you didn't
[Music]
whoa what's up it's john with the dr
john dolone show so glad you're with us
it's so good to have you if you want to
be on the show give me a call
1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to the internets and go to
john delaney.com
ask a-s-k
um
so
man
some people on the internets have a
sense of humor
and
they also know about uh
family trauma
others
are really mad
that i went after
the robert munsch book
where the creepy mom crawls through the
window and tries to murder hug her son
she breaks and enters into his house
and uh luckily he doesn't have
i don't know a shovel next to his bed or
something
so she can hold her grown man with a
mustache and just rock him
while he's in his comatose sleep sounds
good beautiful
so
a couple things number one
some people asked
how would i feel someone said that about
my book number one
um
i try this is like a rule of thumb i
have i try not to include
clear pictorials of generational trauma
in my books and so if i do
i would suggest game on
game one right the other thing is people
do people are mean they say things about
my book it's part of being an author and
putting it out there i will say this
though this is important
um
so
before i say what's important somebody
wrote um
we're i'm from canada and this is like
it's like a he's a canadian expert it's
a huge deal don't run him down and that
actually made me smile i get that i i'm
all in on that and people talk about
about texans even when they're idiots i
always like hey come on man they're one
of my people um
so i i honor that um here's the deal my
wife is a uh children's lit
uh expert and
she was like listen you better make sure
everybody knows that robert munch is
like one of the greatest children's
authors of all time ever in the world's
history
he just laid one giant
rotten egg
once and wait hey listen
poison look what the cat dragged in and
then uh what's the next one that it was
uh uh uh it's it's one with everyone's
has a thorn why can't i think of the
title of it what kind of fan am i anyway
that record uh open up and say ah that's
what it was and then flesh and blood
dude
you can't just do four masterpieces in a
row and so then they came out with the
next record and i still haven't
recovered psychologically i'm still in
therapy it happens it happens so
anyway everybody let's just take 30 off
smile a little bit more and let's not
read books about generational trauma to
our children and let them know one day
when you have your own family
i may just get a ladder and climb up on
your roof and break it in into your
house take you out of
your bed
and rock you
because i it's because yeah all right
let's go to greg greg and boise what's
up greg
hey how's it going dr julian how you
doing good brother how are you man
oh better than i did very very nice
thanks for taking my call for sure dude
what's up
so um i'll try to be like as succinct
and i guess specific as possible um and
that way you can kind of get the
background i think i think my question
is kind of two parts
um so my wife and i we've been married
for about 14 years um got two kiddos i
mean my life's the best thing that's
happening to kids the best thing that
happened to me i've been a cop for about
17 years
15 years down in southern california and
i just lateraled up here to this area
um long story short i can give you the
history of everything as far as my
history but every first responder has
stories right that's right um
but anyways with that being said i've
recently uh been um given the
opportunity to work in a position
basically where i'm going to be chasing
pedophiles you know full-time and doing
like internet crimes against children
stuff
and so with that being said i
i'm kind of thinking like what what
exactly do i do to prep i mean i've seen
stuff and everything else but this is a
whole other level is there anything
mentally that i can do to prep for those
things you know getting ready for that
stuff and then the caveat to all that is
honestly dr d is this that it's man i
the last probably six seven years i'm
just done like i i sometimes i i throw
my key in the ignition and i i'm going
into work and i see the cases i'm
assigned i'm just like i don't want to
do this anymore and i'm i kind of at
this crossroads so that's really where
i'm at and i try to be like i hope
that's assisting because
one thanks for making the call i know
that's a hard call tonight so thank you
for your food thank you for your trust
and
um some of that stuff you've been saying
it out loud is hard and so thank you for
doing that brother um i i wanna
i want you to hear one thing before we
get going and and i'll start pulling on
some of the threads here um everybody
every first responder is a story you're
you're right and your story is your
story
okay
and it doesn't undermine or make it any
easier or any less gruesome or any less
just because somebody else had it too
yours is yours
and your kids wear it and your wife
wears it and you especially wear it and
so um even though it's it's all around
you never compare that kind of stuff
brother it's your story and you've seen
the stuff right
um i'll let's reverse engineer this
conversation
i could not
um i can think of two i think
one or two
i've got some just from working with
college students and having to go
through you know i had worked with i
think was fbi at one point on one
particular case uh
i've got things in my head that will
never go away
okay i could not work that role
okay i honestly can't tell you
how i would even prep for that role
working working sex crimes against kids
um particularly um i've got a couple of
buddies who did that and
um the
i wish i had a better answer for you it
felt dispositional
they just were able to go yeah some ugly
gnarly stuff and somebody's got to go in
there and do it
um and they seem to i couldn't do it
um and remain in retain humanity you
know what i mean because it's some yeah
absolutely
i mean that you've been there before and
even though you're not working the unit
you've seen stuff right and it's it's
it's it's i don't know it enrages me in
a way that i know i couldn't be
objective in that job
that does not have anything to do with
you
my recommendation for you would be
to get with a couple of guys who have
done that some men and women who've done
that and
to ask them about it because listen
somebody has to do that work we need
that done we have we've got
our technologies outpaced our ability to
chase it down and there's a bunch of
people who are in over their heads and
some really dark evil stuff and we need
people like you to chase them down i
don't feel like i'm in a good position
to give you wisdom on it because i know
i couldn't do it anything i'd be telling
you would be all theoretical and
hypothetical
uh well i appreciate i appreciate that
too
how'd you end up um on that is it a
promotion for you
yeah i mean somewhat it's a good
interview it's just um just giving some
of my history and it's a task force with
with the state of idaho that i got put
into and so um
at the end of the day like i told them
even in the interview um when we do this
it's like you know
99 of people out here we can we can have
religious differences political
differences but 99 of people
mostly agree hey
this this guy or gal's got to go to jail
you know 100 of people even pet even
pedophiles believe that pedophiles
should be in jail so 100 percent
yes yeah yeah no it's hey listen
somebody's got to do this work and so
don't hear me say that people shouldn't
do this at all
um yeah let me let me not be i'm kind of
being a coward and skirting the issue
here
the
what you would have to do is have some a
plan in place that is robust
okay okay you would have to say
there will be no
child
um
we don't watch shows in the house that
have anything to do with we will never
watch law order svu at home right that
will never come on here this will never
be entertainment um i will have a
counselor that i talk to off off book
that
um i will be able to process this with
that sort of um evil
just makes its way into your life
and so uh and for those of you who are
listening and i realize i'm i'm having
an inside baseball conversation here
with police officer
when you're doing investigations there's
all sorts of ways to hide stuff there's
all sorts of ways to put things behind
you know walls
when you find it part of the job is
documenting like whenever you see
somebody busted for child pornography
and they say hey there were 750 counts
of somebody had to go through that
computer and scroll through every
picture and catalog it
and then somebody had to go down this
link and chase down that rabbit hole and
get into this chat room to try to find
that and so you end up you cannot be
that sort of uh
plumber and not get
cha-cha all over you right so it's
having a plan that says this is how i'm
gonna stay well in this in this field
um and
having some people in your life that you
can talk to that's non-therapeutic but
that you're gonna go have friends that
are not just all police officers because
that's one of those things when you do
homicide when you do that when you do a
couple of those those fields that is
constant carnage
it shifts your bell curve and it makes
your world feel like everything is
coming down you know what i mean
absolutely and you got two little kids
you'll start eyeballing every everybody
you see i do it man and i've not done
that level of investigation man so
okay so let's back out to the other
thing
tell me about your exhaustion
um you know i i guess my exhaustion
stems from obviously you know
two kids your wife you you're taking
care of everything you're trying to
you're trying to be
i guess be everything to everyone for
lack of better terms i always think of
that old toby keith song but anyways
um
and i think i just you know my son he
had to have heart surgery when he was
two years old um so like that that's
what actually shifted us and i would
have never left the agency i was at in
southern california but that kind of
like shifted my perspective i kept on
saying
god and my family are the most important
but i was living and breathing the job
and i finally said you know what no i'm
done we're going to rip the bandit off
and we moved up here and just wanted to
give my kids the best life they could to
be just to be kids for like a better
training yeah so and so i think go ahead
no you go ahead man
so yes i i think that's i just as some
of the exhaustion stems from all of that
and and but honestly just i i guess
i talked to a couple of my buddies that
i have you know that we've we've you
know we've been through some some things
together and we always said the man
sometimes i just wish i could just go
mow lawns you know and go back to just
mowing an edge
and and i just get to that point but
then
the other side of me kicks in and goes
like you were just saying somebody's got
to do this like somebody's got to
protect those kids somebody's got it
somebody's got to do the job that we're
doing and but i just i i like i said i
just kind of am done i just get to the
point where i'm like i don't want to do
this anymore i'd rather run and operate
my own business i have other plans in my
head that i think about and i just i
like i said i just don't know when to
say when is that when do i listen to
that versus
i just go to work because that's what i
was raised to do is you go to work and
you work hard and that's right well i i
don't i think you've boxed yourself into
an either or corner that i think's not
okay totally accurate and so um
i'm gonna walk you through a couple
things number one
if we just if you and i just are
grabbing a drink and eating chips and
salsa
i would pull out a piece of paper and
i'd just start writing stuff down and
what you've just told me in the last few
minutes you've been a police officer for
this with the same team for 15 years
and suddenly that's gone
your son your two-year-old little boy
had heart surgery
so that safety and security and
innocence gone right then you packed up
and moved halfway across the country and
moving from southern california to idaho
is you you went from earth to mars right
absolutely absolutely a little different
you changed are you a person of faith
i am yes you change churches you so i
want you to hear me say trauma trauma
trauma trauma all on top of your day job
which is always going into other
people's mass are you patrol are you are
you in at a desk you in patrol what do
you do
yeah right now i'm actually a juvenile
detective at large i was on patrol for
the last year and then i just got into
that and then i'll be going to the task
force okay cool so
your exhaustion is well earned
and often what happens is when we get
burnt out when our burnout is an actual
physiological thing it's your body
telling you i can't go anymore
and we often when our body starts doing
that we look around at the nearest thing
and we start pointing fingers at it
often it's a spouse often it's our kids
often it's
um our job and sometimes they're
contributors but the main epicenter here
is my body
and your body's been through the ringer
and you're a guy that holds it all
together for everybody
at work in your neighborhood and in your
home
and
i don't know about you but
i i'm just trying to picture
not only my own heart but trying to prop
my wife up if we were to have that kind
of life threatening surgery with our
with our little boy you know you know
what i mean so you've been through a lot
and so i want you to not make decisions
based on this current
cycle of exhaustion and fatigue because
that stuff's real and
if you can do the healing to heal from
some of that and the healing that sounds
like a cheesy therapy word that means
owning it processing it grieving it
understanding the things shouldn't be
that way and then going to make meaning
and saying hey here comes what comes
next so it's not super complicated it
might take long but it's not super
complicated it's not like this you're
not going to be sitting in a circle
singing kumbaya with people lighting
candles and stuff like that right
unless that's you're into that thing
um
have you
gone down the if you've moved to a new
unit
and you're already getting asked to be
on a task force
are you a certificate collector
a certificate as far as like my the
trainings i've been through are you an
award collector
yes yeah yeah i have i have a few awards
are you really good at what you do is
what i'm asking
yes i i i believe i am i hate i i try to
be assembled as possible but yeah no i'm
i'm good at what i do if you're because
because it's it's rare that somebody's
gonna bump is gonna do a lateral and
then it's instantly gonna get moved up
like that right you know how that goes
there's the old boys who've been in line
for a long time that tells me you're
really good
in in government work and in education
work if you're really good usually it's
because you just played the path that
was laid before you
and
i always thought why wouldn't you just
go do the four things to get this big
fancy award why wouldn't you just do
that it doesn't make any sense to me and
so then you go get that one and you go
get the next one and then you'll get the
next one you're like you mean i just
have to do these classes and do this
hours of service and this and then i get
another award i'm in for that
and here's what i found
especially in police work nursing work
frontline work education
they just lay the path out to success
and i'm putting success in quotation
marks
what it ends up being is somebody else's
path to what success is supposed to look
like
all of this is really fancy language to
say
you my brother have not
in a long long time sat down and asked
yourself what do i need
because you've just been doing what
you're told better than everybody else
and getting rewarded for it and you've
been trying to take care of everybody
else in your life and what i need you to
hear me say is the best thing for your
community the best thing for your unit
the best thing for your family is for
you to be honest about what you need and
go make those things happen and fill the
rest in on the back end
that that makes 100 sense and i i
appreciate that's that's the fear that
because
yeah no it's 100 fair i mean
so so i i think i've talked about this
on the show before
there was one season when i got my my
body was done i was fried 24 7 365 for x
number of years my wife and i ended up
taking a 70 000 household pay cut move
into a new city
and i went from a fancy job to
a fancy job but with a much smaller
group of people to work with i had to i
had to throttle it back
and that was a season that man i went to
more school i got more education i also
learned how to write a little bit better
a lot better i learned how to interact
with people and so i ended up that was a
season of growth for me there's also a
ceiling of heal healing for me
and so i don't think you guys should
take a 70 000
household pay cut or anything like that
i'm just telling you
sometimes there's a season to say okay
i've been through a lot the last three
or four years
maybe task force isn't the right thing
in this moment or maybe getting off for
sure off juvi and moving into this so i
can settle in and sit at a desk yes it's
gonna be hard hard work but i'm not
gonna be running the beat for a season
and i can heal yeah right i can go talk
to somebody and you have great i i don't
mean this in an ugly way you've got
great cover
i hey i'm getting a counselor i'm gonna
end up seeing some dark and heavy stuff
and so i'm going to go have some you've
got some cover right to go talk to
somebody
preemptively right
yeah absolutely
is there any natural breaks are you at
15 20 or 30 does your stuff carry over
with you
so i'll actually know so the way it
works is for i i kept my retirement at
out of interior county and so what i'll
do is i'll end up uh staying out there
and in 20 years i can pull from it if i
want okay and then here i don't know
it's got the rule of 80s it's a little
different so i i've often thought about
that hey in you know three more years
maybe i just pulled the plug and collect
that retirement down there that'll cover
the mortgage and in
perspective my wife and i have been
following ramsay was a prerequisite for
us to before we even got married by our
pastor and uh so we're in baby steps
four five and six uh we you know
i i i don't want to say like we're doing
well and you know what i'm blessed
beyond measure with everything and
that's why i was kind of hesitant to
even reach out and call but like my wife
my wife actually told me last night
before i was going through she's like
you got to talk to somebody so you got
some demons in your head she's like you
just you need to get that out and just
and figure out what's going on i'm like
yeah you're right and not in a bad way
but just
there's stuff in my head you know so i
would love for you to get radical about
your needs
and i'm really proud of you for
listening to your wife i didn't for a
long long time it almost cost me
everything
and when she looks at you and says hey
you're not okay what she's saying is the
man that i love
it hurts me to see you not okay
it's not a judgment it's not a character
assassination it's her saying i love you
and it hurts me to see you hurt
and so
if she's there with you then man you won
the lottery with her and hang on to that
one
and i would love for you to get radical
about your needs and begin to make that
a priority and begin to say okay
here's what well looks like for me it's
an hour before work i just got to have
it by myself and if i can have this hour
here
and i'm going to go see a counselor once
a week and we just i hate to say this
honey we got to start eating different
and i'm going to cancel netflix like the
rest of the country and i'm going to
we're going to start just going for
walks as if it like whatever those
things are
i need a week um every six months just
by myself i'm gonna go hunting on a
hunting trip by myself whatever it is
for you um i want you to be really
honest about those needs and i want you
to make me a promise here just me and
you
um
will you go talk to somebody
yeah absolutely professional
yeah absolutely okay
your uh community's gonna be better for
it and your units can be better for
those little kids that you're gonna be
protecting
uh are gonna be better for it and your
and your wife and kids gonna be better
for it and most importantly you're gonna
be better for it and i'm i'm really it's
like uh
it's a honor of of
it's a career honor for me to get to
talk to you man um cause you're doing it
right
and you've seen a lot of hard stuff and
you want to say what's next um i would
suggest you're not you haven't told me
anything about how you want to bail
it feels you're telling me i'm hearing
that you're exhausted not that you're
done being a policeman
and i think you can heal and i think you
can
create some things in your life where
your needs are addressed and your wife's
needs are addressed and your kids needs
are addressed that will make you a
better police officer it's just going to
be reverse engineering that for the
first time in your life saying what do i
need
what do i need
you're worth it my brother we'll be
right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 percent off
that's betterhelp.com
all right we are back hey don't forget
please um
keep sharing the show with your friends
please if you've read the book and it
meant something to you please give that
copy to somebody or if you love it and
you've marked it all up um encourage
people to buy it listen our show has
spiked in a way that i could have never
imagined and it's just
it's just it's incredible um the the
continued response is incredible and so
i just want to keep encouraging keep
sharing it the response on the book you
guys oh y'all outdid yourselves man it's
it's i just i'm so humbled by it it's
unbelievable so
thank you so so so so much um for
telling folks um and one other funny
thing so hey
it was james and kelly's birthday last
week
um
so james here you go happy birthday
kelly we all went out to dinner or to
lunch a whole gang of us went out um
to this favorite spot we have
and i ordered sushi and
they did anybody get a picture of that
oh you did
you can tell them kelly so it was
actually for my 10th anniversary and we
were all sitting down eating thai food
it was a wonderful surprise and john of
course late
blows in
10 minutes some of us work all the time
but it's cool sure we all came from the
same place order sushi
everybody else is eating their pad thai
or fried rice or whatever and out comes
this ginormous boat they brought it out
in a bathtub
it is a huge boat full of sushi and i
believe my comment was i'm sorry am i
getting too much attention
hey john can i have a weird flex can i
have one lunch for myself i looked at
the table and i thought hmm
everybody's all concerned about kelly
and her big accomplishments and whatever
and then james birthday
i bet i can i can one-up this table i
had no idea man so embarrassing
even the guy started laughing as he
brought it out in a wheelbarrow i was
like what are you doing man i wanna just
anyway there you go happy anniversary
birthday all those things
and cool overalls those are cool
i like them i'm a huge fan
i love mo frost i'm a huge fan i was
going to make a boys to men joke but i'm
not going to all right let's go to ann
in salt lake city what's up anne
hey living the dream how are you john me
too me too
are you a youtuber also because man it
is awesome over here
you're like no i've got a real job
hey so what's up how can i help
hey um so my husband has been bitching
and purging to lose weight
how do i talk to him about how dangerous
this is to his health even though all
he's seeing is the result
and losing weight yeah it's hard because
it works right
yeah
so how long has been going on
um
he started as kind of a coping mechanism
um a couple years ago and we are kind of
going through some marriage
um issues
and
i didn't realize that he had went back
to it once he was getting serious about
losing weight
um so i would say for the weight it's
been about
i would say four to six months
is it daily weekly how often
um
i would say
bi-weekly um that you know
right yeah that i know when he like
feels like he fell off the wagon and you
know he's eaten too much that week or
whatever or like i'll bring home pizza
because i want to surprise him he'll
then he'll just yeah go
do that and it's
yeah
so
my oh man
i have some questions to ask you but i
want to be really careful about how i
ask them one is i don't want to set a
precedent for i'm
for other people listening to the show
that these are always appropriate
questions in every situation
um yeah and
i don't want you to hear them ashaming
questions okay is that fair yeah okay
absolutely
you brought it up so
if if you have a husband who's
struggling with disordered eating
and he's really working towards a goal
how would a surprise of pizza
be helpful or loving for him
it's not it sounds like a thing it's
that's a surprise for you because i love
pizza i love bringing it home
it doesn't sound like that is y'all two
on the same page for let's do something
together for both of us
is it fair yeah
yeah absolutely
did he wrestle with disorder eating
years before
or body dysmorphia is he struggling with
his self-image or is it just something
that
he took on when you're did you almost
lose your marriage
yes was your infidelity involved
no no what happened
um
we're pretty young um and we've only
been married five years this year um and
so
just a lot of growing up to do yeah
there you go we all did it yeah that's
right that's right yeah it's yeah so and
just uh some trust issues and
okay
yeah um so
here's the way forward i think
um i think twofold number one
the conversation is not you need to stop
doing x y and z
all right when that happens
immediately it's fight or flight he's
under attack
and the ability to hear you is off the
ability to process logically what you're
saying is off the ability to respond
clearly is off okay it's all about
survival and sometimes survival is
destructive behaviors all the time
survival is a flow of cortisol and
adrenaline that just melts our bodies
from inside out when it's pervasive okay
my guess is he's been doing that for a
long long time
so the conversation is less about hey
you got to stop doing this and more
here's what i need
here's what i and need
i need the man that i love
to stop killing himself
which is what he's doing
i need um this so so we're not judging
his character right he's clearly hurting
and he's sick and he's covering up
and i don't think this makes him a bad
guy or weak or a coward i think he's
really hurting sounds like he's sick
is that fair
yep
have you felt him to be weak and a
coward and just quit doing this is
disgusting
no
what are you feeling towards him
um i'm feeling
uh
i'm feeling scared for him and
kind of disappointed
in a way
um because i know some of it is
emotional
and i don't a huge huge compliment it's
emotional
yeah
i can't like help him or be there for
him
in the way he needs i can't lose the
weight for him and i can't
you know like
yeah that's right so and there's a
powerlessness to that that you have to
feel if you try to avoid that
powerlessness that that avoidance comes
out in rage and anger and yelling and
you mean looks okay
so own that powerlessness
and then divert that energy after you've
owned it for a season and the season's
like a day or a couple of days right
it's not like a year um and
look unless it may be a year look at him
and
no the only thing i can control is anne
so what he needs right now is somebody
who loves him probably three or four or
five people who love him
who will circle up and say hey
here's here's just the data we love you
and as people who love you we
need you
to love yourself as much as we do we
need you to stop killing yourself
and if you're willing to
get well i'm willing to walk through
hell with you arm and arm and i'll go
with you
um
i'm prepared to do that because i love
you that's the conversation forward not
what'd you eat today did you have it in
did you put sauce on it that's the pro
you know what i mean
and especially not bringing pizza home
to celebrate
um
where does he get where does he get in
mind and that's not the only thing you
bring home by the way is it
no no
um
a lot of times when one person in in a
couple loses weight
the other person resents them because
they have to change their life my wife
for a season was really frustrated that
she couldn't just keep a bag of cookies
in the house it was annoying for her
because she's not the problem i was
and um until she made peace with it and
then she hides stuff from me too by the
way i find that every once in a while
um that's not super healthy but
she ultimately made peace i love him
more than this than a if i need a cookie
i'll go get one and by the way i don't
need those you know what i mean
yeah
a lot of times when somebody's losing
weight trying to go on this journey they
feel the disdain of their partner
and it just spins that shame cycle up
more that not only am i and i'm saying
things imaginary things
not only am i disgusting not only am i
unhealthy
not only am i not attractive
now i'm also
like taking away my wife's ability just
to enjoy dinner the dinner that she
wants to have
and that cycle of shame sends somebody
you see what i'm saying sends them
straight to destructive behaviors
yep
um would you be willing to go all in
with him
oh absolutely where does he where does
he
did he learn the idea that he needs to
lose weight
um just from looking at pictures of
himself and he just doesn't feel
he wants to get back to the way he was
in high school and
um
yeah and we have been working out
together and trying to eat better
together and
um
yeah so what i'll tell you is
i've been in this in this game for 20
something years
and i'm just now signing up for yet
another coach i can't do it by myself
and the
uh he was on the show my buddy lane
norton who's won the he's like set
national records for weightlifting and
he's the protein group he's entering the
nationals again and um in fact by the
time this comes out nationals probably
over and he got a coach
and so i would tell you if y'all are
being serious about it it's time to get
some professional help and stop just
looking at youtube clips
and also your husband's got to go see
somebody and i think that starts with a
couple of y'all um who people who love
him surrounding him and saying hey
we love you enough to tell you that
we're watching you kill yourself and
we don't want to watch that anymore we
love you too much
and it's really important for you i
would spend some time writing down what
do you need
how can he help meet your needs and vice
versa how can you help meet his needs i
think it'd be really important for you
to sit down and say i have not helped
and i'm sorry i'm not going to bring ice
cream and cookies and pizza home anymore
let's get with a coach and get an actual
diet plan that's going to work for us
not a diet plan but it's just a
structured eating a healthy eating plan
moving forward i think diets are stupid
let's get a a
a plan moving forward that we're both
going to be on the same page and there
is going to be days we're frustrated
there's going to be days where annoyed
and we're going to keep plugging along
and keep plugging along and he's going
to have to deal with the mental health
aspect of his disordered eating okay
[Music]
all of that starts with connection all
of that starts with love all of that
starts with a group of people saying i'm
on your team
and that starts with you looking them in
the eye and saying
i'm ready to go to hell back if you are
because i'm in
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to
k in tulsa oklahoma what's up k
no not much how are you not much either
here just
bumming around what's up how can i help
um so
basically
um in june 2020 uh i attempted
you know i i was in the hospital due to
her attempt to suicide and it's been two
years and
basically i just
i need some tools kind of to stay
motivated and
to not hate myself whenever like dark
thoughts come back up
um
and
you know i don't
it's a very it's just so weird like i
you know i love life but i love my
family but it's so easy
for me to get knocked down if there's
just any amount of you know
me feeling anything bad you know like
anybody hurting my feelings
um which are super sensitive
it's like of course i became a live wire
after the incident
um
and
the person you know
there was a lot of things that kind of
made that happen in june
but the main thing was um
my daughter's dad and he moved back
into the house because he was working
for halliburton when the oil field kind
of laid people off he
i told him you know you can come back
and stay until you get a place
and inside i was you know
i guess i was hoping for like my
daughter to have
the life that she hadn't had with her
parents really and um
it's almost like he moved in to just
like totally shoot me down
and um yeah
it yeah there was just a lot of
manipulation and
so whenever i think back on those days
leading up to it and
you know being in the hospital for a
week and then having to go somewhere
else to stay for a week there's just so
much anger that blows up like it was
such an injustice
because nobody knows like
you know what he did or
nobody knows like the full story
and um why does it why does it matter
that somebody else knows
um
i don't know
so as i have like i have
as i'm hearing you talk the question
that keeps coming to my mind is
somebody somewhere maybe multiple people
like who told you
that your feelings don't matter
or who told you that your space is
burdensome that just you being around is
is annoying who told you that that your
parents myself
no but that but that came from somewhere
um
did you get that from your family you
get that from cousins for your uncles
my family mostly my mom's side and
my grandmother like they all
really really struggle with depression
um
and so
i don't know this kind of sounds weird
uh i've always tried to be like the
strong one you know and like keep
everything good and happy and um
but that happened and you know my
mom she already struggled with
depression and she just
it made it so much worse and hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
you didn't make it so much worse
you didn't
you don't have that kind of power you
don't have that kind of
influence
your mom's body is your mom's body and
it contains a cocktail of
genetics and depression is genetic
and she it contains a cocktail of
whether she's gone to see a professional
and she's on medication she's taking
care of herself in therapy and she's
moving her body and exercising and all
the things
life happens
and we all have a series of genetics we
were born with then we have a series of
choices that we make every single day
and when someone's struggling with heavy
depression and you you
okay you deal in the black hole right
you know what i'm talking about
it's like uh being at the beach and all
of a sudden that water you can't touch
all of a sudden right
yeah yeah
and most people are like i'm depressed
okay you know what that's actually like
and what you can't do when you find
yourself at the beach you can't
just suddenly get taller right you can't
just your legs can't just shoot up and
suddenly you can touch the bottom and
you can't just suddenly be a stronger
swimmer right that takes years of
practice on the back end
and you can't suddenly just have a body
like michael phelps that's genetic he
just got that body that he was born a
human fish right
you know
here's what you can
you can say help
and people will come
and somebody along the way told you
you're not worthy of saying the words
help please
and listen to me i'm sorry that nobody
told you that because you're worth that
okay
um
there's a difference between guilt and
shame i don't think you're experiencing
guilt
guilt is i did something that i regret
or that violates my core value and so
let's say you grew up around a lot of
people with depression who are always
attempting suicide and you said i'll
never do that
and then one night you found yourself in
a dark hole and it happened
and you feel quote unquote guilty
imagine yourself picking up a brick and
you're holding that thing that's guilt
yeah when you unzip your backpack and
put that brick back there and carry it
that's shame
yeah it's the difference between
i
did something and i am something
and you have
given yourself a
label of somebody who does these kind of
things and i don't buy it for a second
i think you're about strength and i
think you're about bravery and i think
you were hurting so bad and you had a
gift you got to step back from the brink
that's what i think
and then whenever i woke up there was
such like a
feeling of wow you know no
i try to explain it to like you know my
boyfriend and it just doesn't come out
well no it's an out of body experience
right
it's
yeah
i just you know it's like not real does
it feel like yeah it's like looking it's
like watching a movie with like a like a
blanket in front of it it's like you can
kind of see it but it just feels weird
right
and yes there's never such there was a
feeling whenever i woke up that was just
like so beautiful like nobody can touch
me like like i have me and i will always
have me yeah and
that you know
money i was so worried about money like
things don't those things just don't
matter and it's been two years and i try
to like find that feeling again yes so
getting more different yeah yeah you're
chasing ghosts there
that feeling isn't external that feeling
comes from inside you
okay if you go chasing a feeling that's
heroin right that's chasing that's
that's just chasing the ghost man
like you know like you
that's not where you're gonna find that
yeah you're gonna find it from the
inside out so listen to me
one of the cornerstones of depression is
i hurt
and my hurt is my fault and it will
always be this way
yeah
i'm telling you
if you'll put the work in it will not be
yeah and god nobody's told you this
you're worth the work okay
okay thank you
do you believe that
yeah yeah
i mean
so listen um i think who you are is
beautiful
who you are strong
and who you are is brave and here's how
i can say that because 99 of people have
no idea the
octopus tentacles that have you around
the ankles sometimes wanting to pull you
into water right
and you just look like a sweet old mama
going to the grocery store to get some
milk and bread and god these prices are
so expensive and nobody knows how hard
that next step after the next step after
the next step is right
yeah
so
here's what bravery looks like
are you seeing somebody
yeah yeah
i think it's been like a year and a half
now um
are you medicaid are you on medication
um we'll be cheering
okay
it may be time to go get those checked
out
yeah okay i uh i need i need to find an
actual counselor
that's one thing that he pushes me
towards i had one for two years during
the accident
and um
she
she didn't ask anything like you know
that she should have like about my
childhood like where things kind of
started
and she um
basically anytime i brought up
that things were still sticking to me
and i couldn't hand you know deal with
it properly
she would just tell me get over it it's
a big day
thanks man like no way i hadn't thought
of that
right okay just get over it
so listen if you took your car
to get an oil change
and they didn't put the plug back in all
the oil drained all over the ground
and they were um they were going to
squeegee your window and the the pad was
off and it just raked like
across your windows and it cut into your
window
and then the guy just spit on the
windshield
okay right and then you drove off
listen listen would you never get your
oil changed again no of course you would
no you'd have to
you just wouldn't get it done there
yeah okay yeah so you have to
go talk to a counselor you need to go
back to your psychiatrist or your pcp
and get your meds adjusted and yeah
you've got to go talk to a counselor
please do you promise me i will i
promise no i will that was my plan still
one one thing i do want to ask you yep
um
i had serotonin syndrome and it took
like apparently it took the doctors a
while to figure out that i had that
because it's so rare serotonin syndrome
yeah serotonin
i've never even heard of that is that a
serotonin deficiency i know right
it's it's no it's where you have too
much serotonin in your body and um
yeah
they had to induce me into a coma
because my i could my whole body was
jerking like it
you know serotonin has a lot to do with
your nerves so if it's overloaded like
okay
yeah so um anyway
um my doctor he at first put me on ssris
and that just floods the thing even more
yeah i know um and i waited because i
had i was on one thing and i was having
seizures afterwards for like six months
until i guess my system leveled out
because they weren't able to like pump
my pump my stomach or anything i already
been too long
but um
so the ssris whenever i take them now
that's why i'm on my b trip
is i it's like
it's like i feel it too much you know
like i'm too sensitive to anything
serotonin okay so so there's some
there's some incredible therapeutic
techniques
for
handling
feelings
okay there's rebt there is um
uh i think it's cbt there's several
different things that usually use with
folks who are struggling with borderline
personality disorder
where the feelings feed and i'm not
saying that's what you have i'm just i'm
that's it was designed for that
but
that may be a place to start and what it
does is it it
teaches you here's what my feelings are
doing to my body
and let me weave through that jungle and
find reality
or even though my reality feels this
strong
here's how the rest of the world is
feeling that same thing
yeah and you learn to it's almost like
running on prosthetics right you're
taking a step and your body feels that
you aren't all the way on the ground but
your body's still held up right
okay you learn to
adapt with to your feelings to a
less
non-feeling world basically
um
but listen all of that is um
you getting with somebody that you trust
and the next time you were the counselor
i want you to take the lead when you get
there
okay
here's what that's like
stop carrying the shame around i will
join your other therapist in that okay
yeah you are not a failure
you're not a lunatic you're not a loser
do you believe me yeah
yeah no i do i want you to clip that and
make it your ringtone don't make it your
ringtone that'd be super weird
okay but listen you're not
did you try to take your life yes you
did that happened i'm gonna own that it
happened yeah
there was a cocktail of things that
happened by the way i don't think it was
just that one event i think there was an
entire season right
and you get an entire picture that
wasn't going to come true so yeah
i'm going to create a new identity that
is i'm somebody who's going to live
yeah and not just have breath
i'm gonna have be somebody who has joy
and laughter
and rambunctious intimacy with my spouse
and i'm gonna be
i'm going to live and so then i'm gonna
have to go do the things
that help me to live and if you have a
generational
um
uh
generational depression that goes that
you can look back lineage then you're
probably gonna need medication and
that's fantastic what an age that we
live in when somebody in your situation
can get help
okay
you're gonna have to take it you're
gonna have to go you're gonna have to go
sit down with a counselor and look at
the counselor and say hey i'm gonna
start the meeting off i've got this much
abuse and trauma in my childhood
um
i've had i've been impatient because i
tried to take my life i've how many kids
you have
this one i've got one beautiful little
kid i've got a knuckleheaded boyfriend
i'm trying to figure out
and i need help with all of it but i
especially need help with the depression
and the suicidal ideation i need you to
be that clear
you hedge your bets if you go back and
listen to this when you told me about
what happened
you told me from a position of shame
and i want you to tell me begin to tell
the story from a position of ownership
this happened
and look at me now
yeah okay that
that feeling you said that you felt when
you opened your eyes
it's pretty common there's some um
really remarkable research that people
who
um try to take their life
off the golden gate bridge i think it is
people who lived 90 something percent of
them went on to live their life
yeah what that tells me is they didn't
really want to go down that hole when
they jumped no no that was yet
same with you yeah
yeah i uh i put in an email you know
that's the one thing i really struggle
with is whenever i woke up i just i
couldn't believe i had done that and
then i kind of remembered what had
happened and
i remember
that night when it was happening it was
like i was in the back of my head
yelling at myself don't do that that's
right but i i was in so much pain like i
really just wanted to wait i wanted to
stop that's right that's right but most
of the people i've met with over the
years
um in a similar situation have said
those exact words i didn't want to die i
just wanted this hurt to stop
and you've heard the colloquial is like
a pinterest quote but that's like a
permanent solution to a temporary pain
right literally
um and so here listen somebody told you
that that voice didn't count
and i'm telling you it does
that voice in the back saying don't do
it don't let this guy move in here don't
take one more pill don't pull that
trigger
that voice matters because that's your
voice
fair
so
i'll say it one more time who you are is
beautiful
and who you are is strong
and who you are is brave even when you
don't feel like it
and the next bravest thing you can do
is make that phone call to a counselor
and say today's a day
let him know what happened with your
last counselor
right if i would've got my oil changed i
would tell him hey last time i would got
my oil changed dude spit it and scratch
my car up please don't do that
i would do that same thing right
yeah yeah okay okay
my life is better
because you're still here
hello my kids life is better because
you're still here your kids life is
better because you're still here your
community's life is better because we're
still here and i want you to never ever
forget you are not a burden
[Music]
the people in your life their life is
better because you're in it
and you're worth being well
thank you so much for sharing your story
your brave brave young woman
[Applause]
can't wait to see those pictures of that
wedding we'll see you soon be right back
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show hey
we just got an email during the show uh
jenna got email from elizabeth who if
you remember from a few episodes back
was struggling with
um
using marijuana all the time right
started out i was coping strategies and
a way to get off alcohol and now she is
full-blown can't stop
but she wrote us to let us know she is
nine days clean
nine days sober dude so we are
celebrating you that is incredible
elizabeth we're super proud of you man
it's awesome awesome nine days
nine days becomes ten days becomes two
months becomes ten years i'm so proud of
you good for you
as we wrap up today's show
in honor of
kelly's overalls
not her dance moves her overalls
and probably her senior prom
songs by boyz to men it's called it's so
hard to say goodbye to yesterday
how do i say goodbye to what we had the
good times that made us laugh outweigh
the bad
i thought we'd get to see forever
but forever has gone away you have to be
a pretty poor high school student to see
forever
so hard to say goodbye
to yesterday
and i don't know where this road is
gonna lead all i know is what where
we've been and what we've been through
if we get to see tomorrow
i hope it's worth all the weight it's so
hard to say goodbye
to yesterday
it's also hard to say goodbye to you
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode my last
clinical which is like an internship was
uh with this really great psychiatrist
finnish clinical
a couple days later he sends me this
long-winded message about how he has
feelings for me
which i do not have for him can i go
ahead and still take a job i have an
interview at the end of the month at the
same clinic it's not his clinic but he
worked there
i'm so sorry that you got put in this
position i'm kind of angry about it hey
listen
be super angry about it be furious about
it because i'm pissed i just found out
that my daughter is stripping and i
don't know what to do this is going to
sound different than the answer i would
normally give but i'd go get my kid i
want her to come home i don't think
she'll want to come home i want her to
know mom fought for her
right